in general a lot of the energy over the
years that's right and sometimes
incredibly convincing performances
didn't you like saucers more than others
yeah did you like cross a line you know
was it your fault that you cross the
line or is it somebody set you up oh
you're talking about that yes there was
a plane that I did that I had to uh I
smoked a joint in the first scene and of
course there was a very a very naughty
young actor I was in the play with who
on the opening night with all the
critics the opening night he slipped a
real joint onto the prop table and I'm
out there and I'm just know when you're
acting you overdo everything so when
you're out at a party you take two puffs
and you say okay that's enough I'm so
stoned but I was acting and so I'm just
like
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
I literally between the two of us we
smoked a giant blunt on stick I'm like
man I am in it tonight laughing at me
and the kid who put the joint on the
prop table standing there going and I
just went the girl that I was passing it
to and never smoked pot I up to that
point and smoked a lot of pot so I was
like I know you haven't and I know you
have no Barb's don't ever do drugs okay
we drunk this anecdote for a message
[Applause]
first thing I ever did do it but at the
end of the play I got the best reviews
of my entire career
[Applause]
no way oh I would never do that again it
was a nightmare experience and for the
barbs you're much better off listening
to Nicky than me
[Applause]
[Music]
you